rogon loves to find people to friends
who people we know who post
inspirational [ __ ] and all kinds of
stuff and he's like definitely no
nonsense here I can't get enough of it
the train wrecks people on Instagram who
post inspirational [ __ ] are almost
always people I'm its triggers for me
anybody who'd like the successful stuff
I hate all that [ __ ] well across the
nation because it's procrastination it's
just weird
I gotta get right before I go for what I
want I gotta just get right anything I
don't know just just just get good at
something suck my honey hole yeah get
good at something I again I just don't
know how most people make a living
aren't they worried I was always worried
that I wasn't gonna be able to make
money so it just kept me on the straight
and narrow does that make sense like I
was just always like I don't have time
to do all this dumb [ __ ] like who's
who's got the life I want and now let me
try to do what they do
if what's that will take oh say if they
make you an option make them your
history or me okay be ready to search me
and every person you meet oh this is uh
just a hashtags of inspirational voice
on this man these are girls they can
throw hey I'm sorry she why are we why
are you sorry
after so many years because today I saw
your pain in all daughters are yeah you
wish she also made this up he didn't
read that oh wait
without struggle there is no progress oh
thank God I read now when I'm having a
tough day I can go back to that and read
it get the [ __ ] out of here I like
getting this stuff a little imagination
come on with massive action goes a long
way oh cool
didn't know that it's hard to be just
friends so when you fill in the line
yeah I'm day I had an accident easy to
do this so so go to ask a question good
ask question go ahead raise your hand
Brian hold on hold on now now think
about this do you already know the
answer oh he would do that to him do you
feel like most people knew neither they
always know always
you're about to ask me a question is
really complicated yeah and one time I
asked a question teacher and I knew it's
a bad question I go I think the answer
is it depends right he goes very good
there yes sir
it depends it depends
Tony Holmes I went no way I went to ask
I went to another acting teacher to get
how many people are lost in those acting
classes well I stayed in the acting
class you know 99 I have a Honda I
stayed in the acting last for at least
seven more years because I can't tear
myself away from a train wreck that's my
pretty fun oh dude the also painfully
tacular insanity that you see in an
acting class I knew a guy who who
printed out a manifesto and it said I am
an artist and it was his goals and
handed it out to all of us and said I
want all of you to hold me accountable
to these goals I am an artist well I've
never heard from him since of course
that on that I can't a guy just
disappears Jen that was that was James
Franco became a star yes
no it was just did you get all these
crazies who would stopped the class and
get up and make a declaration and say
some [ __ ] and then Anthony Hopkins came
in I think you need that because so
goddamn tough yeah he also did well I
guess we have sometimes we have a mate
we'd have well I was in a class for a
while with the biggest baddest
[ __ ] on the planet like Burt
Reynolds was in the class sometimes
[ __ ] Neil Simon news later Broadway
royalty but um Anthony Hopkins walked in
one time cuz it friendly used Anthony's
[ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah yeah it was great
cuz you know in acting class it's like
it's religion acting class it's like and
one of those things away for free are
they no no no not not Oscars and he
walks out and somebody said I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about sounds to Land's what it was doing
and he went oh yes so you just he became
the character right and so everybody was
like so when you prepare the research
what are you doing because I don't do
any
they go you know well okay but to
prepare how do you hold on him that
don't do that I just had just assumed
the character and I just do it like he
just he just works on it I'll tell ya so
tell well technique goes a long way in
acting but he's also Jesse's just a beef
you Southie he'd been doing it a long
time in so your ass gonna do miss that
with talent yeah what's with you aunt
they hockey yes yes yes and these guys
are come in and it's just like a whole
different tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]